lágrimas y mucha emoción ayer en la
salida de la audiencia víctimas
aliviadas tras diez meses de un proceso
difícil y agotador
hay que aceptar el llorar porque el
dolor está ahí a pesar a pesar del
veredicto y el sufrimiento está ahí no
deja de ser una etapa
un gran alivio y una impresión un poco
como si uno cierra una puerta y dice ya
está puedo ser parte de esto
intentar retomar el curso de mi vida
poco a poco porque realmente hay que dar
pasos de descompresión pero el lunes
regreso al trabajo como antes el
tribunal condenó a cadena perpetua y
reductible a salah de slam con mirada
fulminante inmóvil dentro del cubículo
no reaccionó al anuncio de la sentencia
para los otros 19 acusados las penas van
de los dos años de prisión hasta la
cadena perpetua revisable al cabo de 22
años
estamos conmovidos por discernimiento y
la inteligencia que ha habido es decir
que a los ayudantes a pequeña Escala se
les ha tratado como tal con indulgencia
sin embargo para aquellos que han
participado de forma muy activa en lo
que pasó diría que su pena es
suficientemente implacable
tres acusados con parecían libres
condenados apenas bajas se echaron a
llorar tras darse cuenta que no volverán
a la prisión momento para la historia a
su salida cuando distintas víctimas los
saludan los reconfortan les dan la mano
les vi llorar Esto me ha estado feliz
por ellos de que ellos también puedan
dejar esto atrás reconstruir su vida es
lo que Les deseamos
ahora las víctimas podrán pasar página y
perseguir su reconstrucción la mayoría
afirma que no participará en un segundo
proceso si los acusados recurren El
veredicto